(hip hop music)
♪ Ya, okay it's Tea With GaryVee ♪
♪ Sip it in for Vee ♪
♪ I know patience is the key ♪
♪ Putting out all of my shit for free ♪
♪ This is Tea With GaryVee ♪
♪ Mic go make the flip ♪
♪ Take your ♪
- Hi, good morning everyone,
April 27th, Monday.
Hope you and your loved ones
are super well and good.
I am in the building,
I'm ready to go right into it.
Tea With GaryVee is live,
Dustin on the one's and two's,
let's get right into it.
- Hey, what's up, what's up?
- What's good, Rich.
- How you doing, Gary?
- I'm really good.
Thank you for doing this.
I'm really happy to be here.
I'm just gonna go straight into it.
- Let's do it.
- So, I got my notes right here,
so I'm like looking at--
so, I wanna get your opinion
on (mumbles) quantity
for consistency purpose
of the content.
So, basically, yeah I'm
(signal distorts speaker)
song engineer and we see
a lot of online content,
DJ's doing live streaming,
artists doing radio shows.
- Hey, Dustin, can we get Richard set?
It's just chopping too much.
Richard, look, work with Dustin,
we're gonna try to get
you set up properly,
cause it's just too choppy.
- Oh, okay.
- Yeah, I dunno what your--
let's get to the next question.
Dustin, let's work on
Richard on the backend.
Get him back in.
Sergio, what's good?
- Doing very well man, good morning,
how's everything for you today?
- Really well, where you from?
- I'm from Chicago.
- Very nice.
- Yes, sir, so hey, first and foremost,
thank you so much for
having me today, man.
It's on honor to be on.
I've been following you for a while
and I've finally really
started to implement
a lot of the things
that you've been talking about,
especially in terms of pillar content.
I have a combat sports
and culture podcast
called, the Fire Podcast
that I've been growing.
For about the last two and a half years,
I have over 200 episodes,
I have over 50 plus interviews.
And I'm at the point
now where I'm actually
really trying to grow the brand.
So, just a long story short,
I say black and Puerto Rican from Chicago.
And I used to compete in
lifelong martial arts,
I used to compete, loved it,
and I had aspirations of going pro.
Unfortunately had cancer,
wasn't able to continue, but for me,
I love the sport,
and I wanted to continue being ingratiated
in the sport.
And the more I went on,
I realized that there was a real
lack of diversity,
especially when it came
to combat sports media.
And that's something that I'm really,
really passionate in.
I'm not able to compete,
but I still want to have something to do
with the sport.
So, I've been doing this for about
the last two and a half years,
and the advice that I've gotten
was from people who were mentors of mine,
but they're into broadcast.
So, they were like, let's just focus on
getting as much information as you can,
and getting your reps up.
So, I feel like I have that,
now I wanna build my pillar content.
I'm starting to do that specifically
with my YouTube page.
I have a lot of podcasts,
but now I'm building that,
but unfortunately I have
someone, for instance,
who has a much larger following than I do.
Not only do they have
a much larger following
than I do, they have a huge name,
and they have a similar name on YouTube,
so it's making me difficult
to be found on YouTube.
Would you have any
advice on how to do that?
- Yeah, yeah, to not worry about that.
I mean, that is--
- Okay.
- That's a complete non-factor.
- Mm-hmm.
- There's always gonna be somebody
with more followers,
there's always gonna be somebody bigger,
stronger, prettier, more money.
It's just completely irrelevant.
You being able to be found on search,
YouTube, if you're in a place
where you're worried about
being found organically
on search on YouTube,
then you're not gonna win.
Because then you're transactional,
you're not a brand.
- Right.
- You understand?
- So, I should just--
Okay.
- Like right?
- Mm-hmm.
- If you're worried about like, damn,
I'm not getting my proper views
cause this other Sergio type character
is stealing my shit.
- Mm-hmm.
- Then you're not winning.
- Okay, okay good.
- Because if people wanna watch you,
they're gonna fucking find you.
- Absolutely.
- You understand?
- Absolutely, yeah.
- Straight up, like if people--
there's people that share fucking names
with fucking more famous people.
- Absolutely.
- Michael B Jordan's
name is Michael B Jordan.
(laughs)
He had to fucking drop the B in there,
but he still got fucking found.
- Absolutely.
He's still getting his flex,
so I'm not worried about that at all.
- Mm-hmm.
- I'm worried that you're
worried about that.
- Okay, okay, so absolutely.
- That's just something
you need to spend--
spending any energy on
alternative situations,
AKA, other people, or what they're up to,
has historically always
been a losing formula.
- Absolutely.
- It just means that you--
- So, just focus on--
that minute that you're--
and you know how it is, right?
Once you get captivated
by some other shit,
now you're watching this shit,
now you're like just--
you're wasting time!
Every minute you're worried about like,
what's his thumbnail, what's his title.
What's going on there or fuck,
he's got a bigger name.
Every minute you spend on that is a minute
you're not spending on your community.
- Absolutely, absolutely.
So, where my focus is
as opposed to sitting
there and actually even
worrying about that,
just keep plugging away.
Focus on making sure I'm putting
as much content as possible.
- Yes, but also, reading the comments
and understanding if
people actually enjoy it
and if it's bringing value.
- Mm-hmm.
- And then mixing up
your game if it's not.
- Absolutely.
- The biggest strength I have
is the evolution of my content,
not just the content.
It's listening and reading every comment.
The reason I was so good at engaging
with everybody on Twitter early on,
and even to this day, still engage more
than most people at the volume that I get.
Is cause I'm actually
reading the comments.
So, just adding the yo, what's up,
or love or thank you, is not super hard.
Most people don't read the comments, bro.
- Absolutely, nah, that makes sense.
- So, read the comments and adjust,
but also not just take
what your audience wants
if you don't wanna do it.
So, it's this fine
balance between what you
try to pull off, and what
do they want from you,
that's a whole other thing.
- Nah, and I feel that,
and that's why even for
myself, I've been trying
to make sure I'm bringing out
as much micro content as I can.
And even doing things, so specifically,
I'm even doing something like
my own show on IG live.
That's kind of building off of that, so--
- What do you want?
- Serg--
- Yes, sir?
- What do you want to happen?
- In terms of that, what I wanna do is,
I wanna make sure--
- Macro, macro, macro, macro,
from a professional standpoint.
- Yes.
- Forget about like--
what do you want to happen?
- I want to be the biggest name
in combat sports media.
I wanna be the black and
Puerto Rican Joe Rogan.
- I understand.
- That is the goal.
- Good, so first be the black
and Puerto Rican Sergio Vecente.
- Yeah.
- But I understand what you're saying.
Listen--
- Yeah, absolutely.
- Rogan plugged the way for years, Rogan--
At this point of your
career, Rogan was playing
standup shows for 13
people in fucking Iowa.
- True.
- So, like--
- Absolutely.
- But it's really true Sergio.
- Yeah.
- It's really true.
Where people get confused
is where Rogan's at now
comes on the back of fucking 20 years
doing standup where nobody gave a fuck.
- Absolutely, absolutely.
- But I really wanna drill this into you
and everybody else.
- Mm-hmm.
- Two years ain't shit.
- Absolutely.
- But a lot of people think it is.
- Mm-hmm, so just
continue building in terms
of the pillar content,
and even if I have my pillar content,
I wanna make sure that--
- By the way, everybody whose trying
to understand what Sergio's saying,
because I know a lot of you might be like,
what the fuck is pillar content?
If you Google GaryVee content model,
pillar content is like a podcast or a vlog
that is like your main thing.
And then what you do is you look,
you take it and you post at it,
just like, this is my
main thing right now,
Tea With GaryVee as the pillar content.
And I'm sure everybody who follows me
on Instagram seen the clips in Instagram.
That's how you take the micro content
from the pillar content,
just so everybody knows.
But yeah, the main thing, Sergio,
that I really wanna make sure you know
is that Joe Rogan, two
years into his career,
on this exact day, on
this exact many days in
the way you're in,
was doing standup for
seven minutes on a set
in some bullshit club in
fucking San Francisco,
and nine people watched.
- Absolutely, yeah.
- And I need people to understand that.
- Mm-hmm.
- Two years into my content career,
I had 140 winos watching
me on an old YouTube
desktop only no fucking mobiles out yet.
The mobile phone wasn't even invented yet
as we know it, you know?
- Right.
- So, I need people to fucking wake up,
what I mean by patience.
- No, I understand that, especially--
- And by the way,
you've been going at it two years.
- Yes, sir.
- 98% of this room that's like upset
that it hasn't happened are fucking
three episodes in.
- Yeah.
- People don't fucking get it, bro.
- Yeah, and don't get me wrong,
I love doing this.
The goal for me is, I wanna make sure
I'm doing this for the rest of my life,
I wanna (mumbles)--
cause I'm (overtalking
drowns out speaker).
- I'm hearing you, I'm hearing you,
I'm hearing you.
- Yes, sir.
- That's why I'm not giving you
the do you love it speech.
I'm giving you the,
you got a lot more
fucking work to do speech.
- Absolutely.
- All right, man, take care.
- Yes, sir.
Thank you, sir, I appreciate it.
- Richard, what's good?
- I dunno if it's clear right now,
it's very choppy.
- It feels better.
Feels better on my end.
- Better?
Okay.
- On my end, yes.
So, the DJ's--
- Okay, cool.
- I see all that, we're
talking about quantity,
quality, keep going.
- Yeah, so basically, yeah,
so I noticed there are a lot of people
doing different things
to share their content.
But I noticed that a
lot of corner to corners
when it comes to audio
quality, student quality
(signal distorts speaker)
How can I say, very
cautious about the packaging
of the content.
I wanted to ask and see is there
(signal distorts speaker)
- Dustin, we're gonna have to reset it.
Dustin, we're gonna have to get--
let's get him setup for tomorrow,
because we're having a
quality conversation,
and his stuffs all chopped off.
Let's go to the next one, Dust,
let's give this man--
- (laughs) Yeah.
- Richard, we'll get
this figured out, bro,
if not, tomorrow.
- No problem.
- Appreciate you.
All right, let me just say what's up.
- Big up to Ed Borough, James Jeursten,
Carolyn G, what's good?
Graham Hayes in the building.
Card Guy Cody, what's good?
Adam Grantham, what's good?
Summer, Winter, what's good, what's good?
Hakim Draper, what's up,
what's up, what's up?
John Phillipe Muenos, appreciate it.
Rap and Combat, what's good?
Saint Love Kick, what's good?
Semera Tosh, right Dust.
Jessica, how are you?
- Hey, how are you?
- I'm super well.
- I am trying to navigate several jobs,
and of course,
trying to get some side things going,
and I'm getting a little overwhelmed
with the social media.
Between the LinkedIn, the Facebook,
the Instagram, the Tik Tok.
Like everything is just trying
to post more than once a day, it's--
and then of course, working several jobs,
I only have maybe an hour a day.
Cause sometimes--
well, right now, it's been a lot easier
because of the quarantine.
I've had a couple of jobs lay me off,
but fortunately I have two others
that I'm still working on.
So, I feel like I have
a little bit more time,
but I know when the quarantine
is lifted and I go back, I mean,
I'm up at 5:30, and I'm
working until like 09:00,
so I only have about an
hour for social media.
- First of all, it's amazing,
your work ethic is inspiring.
So, a couple pf things here, one,
you can't beat yourself up.
Obviously you're carrying so many jobs
because they're all
paying at a micro level,
and so the combination of it allows you
to kind of pay your bills, right?
So, there's three core things here, one,
not beating yourself up
that you only have one hour
when you're working so hard.
And then yes, it will take longer,
but you're fulfilling
your responsibilities
while building towards your future.
So, judgment of yourself too,
are you overthinking
your content on social,
so then it's slow, right?
If you're over worried
about production value
or perfection, that could
be another thing, right?
- One of the--
well, one of my jobs
is in mortgage lending,
and with that, I have to be careful
of what I post.
- Of course.
- A lot of people depend on making sure
that I know my stuff, and
with mortgage lending,
it changes on the daily.
- I understand.
- It changes every day
I wake up, it changes,
so I have to be--
So, yeah, that does take a lot of--
a little bit of time.
- That makes sense.
(overtalking drowns out speaker)
But I assume your side thing--
but isn't your side thing around--
what's your side thing,
your social media side thing?
- Working out basically, helping lending.
- So, that's what I'm talking about,
I'm not talking about--
- Okay.
- I'm talking about that hour.
- In that hour when it's overwhelming,
my question is, are you overthinking it,
over perfecting it, that's number two.
And then, number three
for your situation is,
is there any way to lower your expenses
so you don't have to cover four jobs to--
- Right.
- Pay for your lifestyle,
like what's going on
on the expense side with
roof and transportation
and food, and then the
thing that I always get
most excited about, which is;
what other things are being bought
that are leading to a vicious cycle?
- Mm-hmm.
- Cause you're in a hardcore cycle, right?
- Right.
- 5:30, 9:30.
- You're just working to sustain--
I mean, you're just working.
- Well, it's nice because the three,
well, the three of them are part time,
and I get to make my own hours.
And once I get--
so, if I get a loan,
a lot of it depends on timing,
and so, I focus just on that,
and I put the other two aside.
So, it's more of, I work full-time,
7:00 to 3:00, and then from 3:00,
to whenever work.
If I have a loan, I'm in there,
and I try to get the loan out the door
cause the timing is
everything to these realtors.
- What would you like to happen, Jess?
Like in the super macro,
are you trying to have
a life and lifestyle
health and wellness platform,
that that's your full-time career,
or is it something else?
- Honestly, I'm still
trying to figure that out,
that's why--
- That's okay.
- I just started listening to your content
in August, and I was like, okay,
now I really have to start this.
Started a couple of pages,
and then now I'm just
kind of working, getting them.
I mean, I'm not worried about followers
and how much I have and things like that.
I know it's like watering a plant,
you just gotta wait till it grows,
but my problems is, is--
- But we all wanna see a little traction
to give you a little optimism
that you're fucking--
that the water's hitting
the fucking roots.
- Right, true.
- You know?
- Mm-hmm, well, I guess my--
- Yeah, go ahead.
- My other issue is that within an hour,
I have to do social media for not only
the working out, but the mortgage as well.
So, that hour is for both.
- Yeah, I get it.
- And it's hard.
- Have you considered maybe cutting one
of the other kind of part time jobs
to give you back that two to four hours?
- I have, I really have,
but sometimes when a loan comes in
and I push everything aside,
it's just all it is,
is for that loan, but--
- That makes sense,
cause that's where your economics are.
- Yeah, yeah.
- But I mean, but sometimes
the loan's not coming in,
but you're still going to that part time--
what's the shittiest
of the part time jobs?
- What do you mean?
- Which one do you like
the least of the three?
- Oh, geez, it's the part time
at a private school, yeah.
- Yeah, I mean, I would highly, highly
debate cutting that one out to give you--
- Yeah.
- How many hours a week
are you putting into that?
- For that one it's like three hours,
it's not that much.
- I want those three back.
- Yeah.
- Cause that three is gonna give
you less tension on what you've started
getting focused on since August,
and now you're down to four hours.
- Right.
- And you're gonna be able
to get a lot more done
and that's four hours,
but it's really six
because the transportation,
the time, the prep.
It's not just the three hours
you're in that building.
- Yeah, and then I guess,
my other question is,
how do you not get lost
in starting--
having so many avenues, having a job,
and then a hustle,
and then how do you not get lost in that?
- By realizing you're looking to be found,
not that you're lost.
- Okay.
- It's perspective.
- Yeah, that's true.
- You see where I'm going?
- Yeah.
- If you looked at it
as, this is the process
that I'm doing to get found,
versus, am I lost in this?
No different than when I--
you know how much I hate exercising?
I hate it more than the Patriots.
- Well, I'll tell you something,
I don't like to--
- But real quick, lemme
finish this thought
and then just jump in.
- Okay, sorry, go ahead.
- But when I'm doing it, I'm like,
this is me, I don't like this,
but this is doing something good for me.
And then it became
something good in my mind,
you just need to make
that something good in your mind.
That you're not getting
lost, you're working
through the process of being found.
- Yeah, that's true.
- Make sense?
- Yeah, I was gonna say,
anytime somebody goes to work out,
I always tell them nobody--
like not even myself, I love working out,
but I love the after process,
not going into it.
- Me too, oh my God.
You have to such--
- Going into it is never good.
- And that's what you need to do here.
You're not lost or helter skelter,
you're in the process of
finding what you want.
- Perfect, thank you.
- Good luck.
- Hey, thank you so much for that.
- You're welcome.
Jared, what's good?
Mike Z, what's good?
Yogi C, what's good?
Saint Love Kick, one more time for you.
All right, leave a comment if you haven't,
let's keep it going.
Braden.
- Yo, what's up, Gary, how are you?
- Life is good, bro.
- First thing, thank you.
I mean, for all the
people that can't say it,
thank you, you know what I'm saying.
- I appreciate it.
- My question is, so
I graduate in December
with an accounting degree.
I'm just gonna read off
so I don't miss anything.
How do I balance wanting
to try every job field
that I'm interested in?
I've always wanted to coach basketball,
be involved with games somehow,
but at the same time, I
also love flipping stuff.
Like I said, I'm an accounting major,
so I'm balancing all those things,
and just looking to find somewhere
where I can give everything.
Cause I know how I work,
and I work my face off.
- What's the fear of picking one?
- I guess, to just getting started.
I've been--
like the other day, everybody's like,
a lot of people are
fussing about quarantine
and stuff, and it's a crisis and what not.
- I've literally sat on a Zoom call
with college coaches for three hours
and listened to them teach.
That would have never have happened
if this didn't happen.
- That's right.
- So, the fact that like,
I go to Memphis.
- I see it.
- So, I DM'd a coach, and I was like,
"Hey coach, how can I get on this?"
And he just sent me that link.
Stuff like that, so I'm working to get in,
but then also, I love--
you talked one time about juggling,
like if you've got 17 balls in the air
and you drop three,
you still got 14, but if you got three
and you drop three, you got nothing.
- Or if you got one,
but you're looking over in the corner
and you're like, I like that ball better;
that's what most people
that are watching right now are doing.
- Exactly.
- They're juggling one,
they think they're on the focus.
The problem is, they
don't like their ball.
- Exactly, and so, I like--
I love juggling, like your structure.
- So, do that.
- Yeah.
- Because you're asking me to not juggle.
- No, no, I like--
- You like--
- I think the questions
like, where to start.
- Where to start with what?
- Finding the actual career.
I know career's a different term
that it was 20 years ago,
cause we're not locked in.
I'm a teacher, I'm a
doctor, I'm a whatever.
So, I think just having peace and like--
- Well, let's break it down.
Flipping is a career and
and an entrepreneurship
that you can just flip.
- We've made--
I've made easily, my parents and myself,
I made two grand off Facebook in the last
three weeks selling stuff.
We've been going crazy, bro.
I just moved out my room cause the audio
was messed up.
My room is like--
I just been going through what can I sell.
- Love it, it makes me happy.
I love when people are
listening and executing.
It's real, right?
- Yeah, 100%.
I found you on Trash Talk--
- Yeah.
- It's so easy, and so much--
- So fun, so why not that,
why can't that be the starting point?
- I think the thought
with that one is scalable,
how do I make it bigger?
I know more time into it is easy, right?
- You can make $100,000,
there's flippers that
make a million dollars.
They start with one off stuff,
and then they realize
they want more scale,
and then they start
wholesaling from close out
places and doing Amazon versus eBay.
- Yeah.
- I think you actually
don't think it's a career,
which is why that one's like--
I think what you're asking is like,
the basketball coaching one more than--
or whatever, more than the flipping one.
Cause the flipping one,
you've already started.
- Right, and I remember like,
I had a teacher at school,
I'm an accounting major, so--
- That's already a bad
start to a sentence.
- What, teacher at school?
- (laughs) Yeah, I remember
when I had a teacher
at school, I can't wait to hear the rest
of this thing, go ahead.
- Oh, you're gonna love this,
so I'm literally walking
down the hallway one day
and she's like, "What do you wanna do
for a career and whatever?"
I was like,
"I think I'm gonna end
up coaching basketball,"
and she's like, "Well,
that can be a hobby,
that's not really a job."
- Yeah, punch her in her fucking face.
- I was like, Penny Hardway
is on this campus right now,
what are you talking about, dude?
This is multi million dollar industry.
- By the way, by the way!
If it was a $48,000 industry--
- Exactly.
- You'd be happy, which oh, by the way,
is how much she's getting paid.
- Yeah, exactly, I literally wrote down
last night when I was looking
through the questions
you posted on LinkedIn
the other day;
it's not how much money you make,
but rather, how you make your money.
- 100%.
- That's it.
- And even more importantly,
the man I appreciate,
that's more about like,
don't be a scam artist.
To me, the bigger one is,
if we have to redefine success
equals happiness, not money.
- Yeah, exactly.
- That teacher, who I'm sure is lovely,
if she thought success meant happiness,
not money, she would
have been proud of you
when you said, I wanna coach basketball.
- Yeah.
- Because coaching basketball,
as somebody who wants to coach basketball,
sounds like a lot of happiness to me.
- Yeah, I put out a post on LinkedIn,
and I was like, I got
a bunch of colleagues
at school and stuff, and I was like,
"If every job paid the same amount,
what would you be?"
I had a buddy of mine post like,
"I'd be the ball boy for my favorite
professional soccer team."
That is happiness, that's doing what you--
- I think a lot about that.
I think a lot about being the ball boy
for your favorite soccer
team, making 41,000
a year, 29,000 a year,
and then subsidizing it with side hustles
that you like.
And I just wish people knew that
there's as many people
making 52,000 a year happy
as there are making 15 million.
There just is.
- Yeah, making tracks.
- We have to--
once we redefine success,
starting in a capitalist
country like America,
but many other places in the world.
If we can figure it out
as a collective eight
billion people, to make
that happy, not money.
- Yeah.
- The world would be in a 400 trillion
time better place.
- Well, I think you're
starting to think like--
I mean, as a 20 year old
male, you're doing that.
So, I think--
- Yeah?
- Well, you finish, and I'll ask you.
- I think you have your career of flipping
in front of you.
I think the basketball one is,
you've already learned how to do it.
You DM coaches, and Eric Spulstra coaches,
he reached out cold to do video tape
for Pat Riley, and away he went.
- Yeah, who makes the play offs first,
Knicks or Jets?
- Jets.
- (laughs) Jets?
- And it won't be next year,
but that's how worried
I am about the Knicks.
(laughs)
- Bro, (mumbles) take
Antonio Gibson so bad.
- Yeah, I thought there was a real--
I thought there was a chance.
- Yeah.
- I thought there was a chance.
Anyway--
- I appreciate it.
- Thank you brother, take care.
- Bye.
Talk to you soon.
You can be really happy if you know
how to manage your money at 50K a year.
If you don't spend 70,000
a year, you're set.
Or, yeah, let's keep this going.
Sean?
- Hey, Gary, how are ya?
- I'm quite well, how are you?
- Good, good.
Thank you so much for everything,
like everybody says.
- Thank you.
- I will jump right into
it like everybody else.
I'm a leader in the restaurant industry.
- Okay.
- Right now, it's
obviously a little harder.
- Yup.
- I've always been able to do what I love,
whether it's this or professionally
dancing before this.
- Good for you.
- But it's getting harder
and harder to do that.
Even before this pandemic,
the restaurant industry was, I think,
in a little trouble because
costs are increasing
and people's perception of what food costs
wasn't adjusting accordingly.
- That's because most people don't build
a brand, which allows them to charge more
than most restaurants are transactional
based on location, based on just history.
I couldn't agree with you more,
but I don't think that was--
I don't think that's
the issue of the world
and customer expectation.
I think that's the issue of restaurateurs,
who are not adjusting to the reality
of the marketplace.
I really mean that.
- Yeah, yeah, I guess,
a lot of restaurateurs are kind of stuck
in their ways,
but now that we kind of have a restart;
what do you think are the business models
and or ideas we can--
somebody should be pursuing.
- I think restaurants need to realize
their omni channel,
AKA, catering, delivery,
and the restaurant itself,
and maybe even in the CPG business;
consumer product goods.
Taking their number.
If I'm a restaurant right now,
I'm inventing an incredible
peanut butter desert
with my desert chef,
and then I'm starting
a peanut butter brand
on the back of it.
Like literally the
peanut butter explosion,
and then in the line
items of the description
on the menu, it's like, Jets peanut butter
is the peanut butter we use.
And then I'm packaging Jets peanut butter,
and literally selling it for $19 a jar
on Amazon and jetspeanutbutter.com.
I'm fucking being an entrepreneur.
Everyone's fucking do--
Sean, I think you can
see you've hit a button
because let me tell you where
the energy's coming from.
I have a lot of friends
in the restaurant business.
- Yeah.
- And they keep crying,
and I keep telling them they have
to fucking innovate.
You know who else cried?
Blackberry, problem, the iPhone came.
Nobody fucking cried
for Blackberry, right?
You know who else cried?
Kmart, JCPenney's and Sears.
They were the leaders,
nobody cried for them
because Walmart and Amazon came along.
I'm not gonna cry for a restaurant
who hasn't done dick shit in evolving
their business for 11 years,
and just relies on people showing up
to their fucking front door.
I'm not, I'm not gonna cry for that.
Get a charismatic bar tender,
fucking change the menu.
Fucking start marketing
on fucking Instagram,
fuck that, man, fuck that.
Because once you build a brand,
all of a sudden, their chicken masala
can be fucking $28 instead of $22,
which fucking saves you on the cost
of the rising fucking masala.
I'm not gonna cry, I'm not.
- I completely agree.
- No, but I'm passionate about this one.
- Yeah.
- Everyone's fucking
crying, well, guess what?
Like fuck!
So many of my friends are like,
I'm like, we have friends
that are fucking killing
it cause they fucking
actually believed in
Postmates and Uber Eats
and you were a fucking ideological
fucking lazy fuck.
Cause it was working, fuck you, you lost.
That's just, you have to understand,
that's raw, but that's
the truth of business.
That's just the game.
- Yup.
- That's the reality,
the market is the market,
is the market, is the market.
If you think a customer's supposed to cry
that your fucking broccoli costs are up,
they don't give a fuck.
- So, when you're talking to your friends,
do you ever think of,
if you just did this,
like almost a new--
a tactic outside of the
traditional delivery
curb side pick-up.
Is there any, something that you're like,
this concept could work.
- Yes, the one I just told you
about the peanut butter.
- Got you there.
- If you're a restaurant
serve your own butter
and started a butter brand,
and sell it on Amazon.
If you're restaurant serve your own
salt and pepper, name it, brand it,
instead of basic salt and pepper,
and fucking do something.
Like when you go to the
fanciest restaurants,
you know how they play at their fucking
five star level.
They're like, the butter is brought to us
by cows from fucking Vermont,
and the cows name is Don.
And it's like a whole fucking show,
that's how they fucking
charge you $1,000 a meal
instead of $28 a meal.
- Yeah, true.
- Brand.
- And then, brands sometimes
depend on uniqueness,
when you're doing brands especially
on social media for restaurants,
same tactics as an individual probably.
- Yeah, I mean, look,
it's all story telling.
How do we--
how the fuck can we
compel you to get excited?
And a lot of times, that's the personality
of the chef, or the
bartender, or the hostess,
or the owner.
Or it's the unique way.
You know what always
fucking gets me, always?
The people that have burgers,
and they talk about the grill,
how they've never cleaned it in 29 years.
So, all the fucking shits on it,
I'm like, man, I'm gonna fucking go--
next time I'm in Virginia,
I'm gonna fucking--
before I go to that meeting,
I'm gonna go to that place cause I gotta
fucking taste what's on the fucking grill.
- Yeah.
- It's story telling,
this is all story telling.
Tell, convince people
why they need to go to your place.
90 fucking percent of restaurants
just like fucking focus
on fucking location.
- Yeah.
- I'm here, as if like being in business
for 20 years is the reason you should
be doing well.
Literally, one of my friend's like,
"Gary, I've been here for 22 years."
I'm like, "And?"
(laughs)
Who gives a fuck that you've been there
for 22 years?
- Yeah.
- I'm a local institution, to who?
- So, it's still a good time to enter
the restaurant industry,
if you're willing to do these things?
- Best!
Best!
You ready for this?
Here's why, post COVID,
people not paying rent,
everything got fucked up.
Rents gonna be down.
- Yeah.
- There's never--
My man, there's never a bad time
to start a good business.
- Awesome.
- The problem is, people
are starting to realize
that they were sitting on bad businesses
because the first six years,
they poured their heart and soul into it,
but now it's cruising.
And they're in passive income mode
cause their management works,
their location works, well, guess what?
No such thing as passive in business
because there's always a tornado
waiting to hit you.
This time, it was fucking COVID.
- I'm actually in Tennessee,
so we got hit by a tornado and COVID, so--
(laughs)
There is tons, and massive
amounts of opportunity
right now, so I was wondering, so we--
- Jesus Christ.
- Are grasping it, you know?
- Yeah, I agree Sean, first of all,
that's crazy, that's--
when that shit happens,
when I make up analogies
and the person's like, yeah, actually,
that shot just fucks with me (laughs).
Anyway, listen brother, it's hard,
but it's supposed to be hard.
- Yeah.
- People need to know what
they're signing up for
when they start a business.
- Yeah.
- It's the hardest thing.
It got really glamorized the last decade,
cause entrepreneurship got cool.
Because fucking Justin Timberlake
played Sean Parker,
and delivered a really
cool line in a movie
that everybody watched,
and it fucking exploded, right?
(laughs)
And then the internet came,
and characters like me popped up,
but they didn't see what
we did for 15 years.
They don't see what we're doing at night.
They don't see me last night at 11:00 p.m.
going through emails,
worrying about a fucking pitch today.
It's work.
- And that's the key is like,
restaurateurs are known for doing 14,
18 hour days, six, seven days a week,
which is a normal thing.
- Tough business.
- It's just normal.
- Yeah, that's the normal, listen--
- But it's where you put your time now,
versus what they're used to putting
their time, right?
- That's right.
- You hire people to do those tasks
that have been known
for the past 15 years,
and we can focus on these new tactics.
I guess, that's--
- So many restaurants thought pouring
another 50,000 into
renovating their fucking bar
was what they needed to do,
when they needed to hire somebody
to do social media everyday.
- It makes a lot of sense.
- It's about decisions, bro.
It's about decisions, you know?
- Makes a lot of sense,
thank you very much.
- Yeah, you got it, brother.
Great conversation, thank
you for spurring it.
- Thank you.
- Yeah, that was good.
Was super interesting shit.
I'm sure, I hope that
helps a lot of people
because it's real.
This is a fucking raw game.
This is not for the faint hearted.
Owning a business is like parenting
a child, it's forever.
It's not when your kids go off to school
and it's over.
It's fucking forever.
Parenting a child goes
until you fucking die.
Every day you'll worry.
You ever see those 90 year olds
that are hanging out with
their 70 year old son
and still telling them
to tuck in their shirt?
That shit's forever.
Fucking forever, and that's a business.
Let's keep it going.
- Hi, Gary.
- Hey, Drew B.
- How's it going?
- Well.
- Excellent, I wanna
start by thanking you,
and this will lead right
into my question too.
I found you about six months ago,
I co own an all natural skin care company.
All natural, eco friendly, all that stuff,
and thanks to you, we got on Tik Tok,
and about a week ago I
had this 10 second video.
I got all self- conscious about,
I was about to delete it,
decided to post it anyway,
and it just went crazy.
We sold out of everything, except for one
of our products, doubled our followers.
It's just, Tik Tok's nuts (laughs).
- I've heard.
- Yeah, yeah (laughs).
So, I just wanted to thank you for that.
- So, that you can't imagine,
say that one more time for everybody
in the back, because it's super important.
- It is.
- Not the part of the piece going viral,
the point of you actually
driving business results.
- Yeah, it's crazy.
As long as you don't get
inside your own head,
you just keep pushing stuff out there.
Don't worry about looking stupid,
cause I came this close
to deleting my clip,
right before I uploaded it.
- And how much worth
of stuff did you sell?
Roughly.
- In two days, it was like $2,000,
which is a lot for us.
- It's a lot.
- Yeah.
- It's a lot for anybody.
- Good for you,
congratulations, keep it going.
- Thank you, I appreciate it.
So, that leads right into my question,
which is, you say to find what works
best for you, whether
it's typing, audio, video.
What works best for me
is video, I found out,
especially quick, goofy clips
where I'm acting silly
while giving out information.
But you also say, try
get on as many platforms
as possible, and alter what you're doing,
depending on the platform.
But what works for me,
it almost seems like it's tailor made
for Tik Tok, and it
doesn't do quite as well
for Instagram and Facebook.
Do you think I should just--
should I share those--
- I think, if somebody finds a place
that's just fucking made for them,
I still believe you put
70% of your energy there.
- Okay.
- And you still put 30% of your energy
in the other places.
- I got it.
- Because A, people
become one dimensional,
and then eventually it teeters out.
What's your Tik Tok handle, by the way,
cause I wanna make sure everybody
gets to follow you?
- My Tik Tok handle, Naked Ape Brand.
- What was that?
- It's Naked Ape Brand.
- Naked Ape, like an Ape that's naked?
- Yes, like humans, Naked Ape (laughs).
- Yeah, so like Babe, my favorite brand,
street wear brand, I love that.
Naked Ape, good, okay.
- Okay, well, that's
pretty much my first--
- I love it, I love it.
70% on Tik Tok right now.
How many times a day are
you posting on Tik Tok,
once every couple of days or what?
- I aim for four or five a day, yeah,
it depends on the day.
- That's great.
That's great.
- Awesome, what we're trying to do--
- And how many posts did you post before
that one went bananas?
- That's the thing, well,
first our fourth post
went viral, almost a million views.
We got sales from that
too, not quite as many,
cause it wasn't about
the business as much,
it was just a general, goofy thing.
But to get this one, we only posted
probably 50 times,
and I've only been on
there for like two months,
and halfway through it teetered out.
So, it's really incredible
how quick it happened.
And that's the other thing
I wanted to talk to you about too.
I mean, everything you just said
makes perfect sense
about the 70% versus 30%,
but at the same time, it's like,
it's hard to find motivation
for these other platforms
when you just post something on Tik Tok,
and it just goes.
You know what I mean?
- Listen, people love
instant gratification,
why do you think I--
- Right.
- And it goes, and it works,
why do you think I've been yelling
for a fucking year
to get all these fuckers on there?
- Right, right.
- Wait, can we not--
People are saying they
can't find your Tik Tok.
Did we get the right--
Dustin we get the right thing?
- I saw, when it came out,
for some reason, some people
have trouble finding it, I don't--
Naked Ape Brand, yeah, that's right.
I dunno why it happens,
but you search for it,
and Tik Tok hides it from people.
- Mm-hmm, okay, gotta figure that out.
- Great.
- Listen, brother, keep going,
70%, don't get discouraged with four views
on Instagram while
you're getting a million
on Tik Tok, because you wanna diversify,
and you never know when
a platform disappears.
Vine's not here anymore,
and some of the Vine kids,
- Right.
Like King Batch and others were smart
and went on Instagram,
and Snap, and now Tik Tok.
Others just were one dimensional,
didn't wanna leave Vine
as it was declining
and got hurt.
You always have to hedge the platform
that's working for you the best.
- Yeah, just be prepared,
and then real quick,
podcast, Twitter, LinkedIn,
for direct consumer
all natural skin care company,
do you think those are important?
- Yes, I do, podcasts especially
could be a monster.
- Okay, just need to find something
I can talk about.
- True, true.
The skincare product is the commodity.
No matter how good your
fucking product is,
I promise you on my
life, it's the commodity.
- Right.
- The marketing plan is the variable.
- Right, right, okay.
- Go ham.
- All right.
- All right, see ya.
- I appreciate it, Gary.
- You got it, bye-bye.
Let's keep this going.
Vine is forever, I love that, Adam,
Vine is forever.
Vine is forever because
the nuances of Vine
are still so important.
So much of what works on
Tik Tok is Vine culture,
so Vine is forever.
I mean, so many of the things
I learned on My Space, or Social Cam,
or Daily Booth are the things
that are foundational to how I do content.
Viddler, Ustream, this is Ustream,
I just did Ustre--
What I'm doing right now is Ustream.
I used to do this on
Ustream in 2009 or 10,
so all right, let's keep it going.
- Hey, how's it going?
Good bro, how are you?
- I'm doing good.
So, real quick, I just wanna thank you
for being on here,
and so my question for
you, kind of comes back,
cause I was listening
to a podcast of yours
a couple of days ago, and
I think it was called,
How to Not Give a Fuck
What People Think About You.
(laughs)
And in that podcast,
you were asked how to
develop self-awareness.
So, I'm gonna ask you that same
question again today.
How do you think that you would go about
developing self-awareness?
- Yeah, I've thought about this a lot.
What's your name, by the way, my friend?
- Joshua.
- Joshua, so self-awareness
is a real tricky one
because if you really have it,
it leads to a lot of good.
And I think a lot of people don't have it,
and I've been thinking about this
for a long time.
I don't have a tremendous answer,
but I do have my best answer.
That I've gotten feedback
has worked for some.
I think the best thing one can do
when they're worried about self-awareness,
is spend a couple of weeks to a month
taking the four to seven people
that they spend the most time with.
Whether they're close friends, co-workers,
or family members,
and spending a month
basically telling them,
listen, I'm genuinely worried
about my own self-awareness,
and I wanna give you a full month of this.
I'm gonna ask you every
day, but in a month,
I wanna sit down, and I want you tell me
what you think I'm good
at, and what I'm bad at.
And I'm telling you,
mom, dad, uncle, brother,
best friend, co-worker, suite mate,
college room mate.
I'm telling you, don't be mean,
but tell me the truth,
and I won't be upset
because you're doing me a huge favor.
What have you been thinking about me
that you've never said?
Am I full of shit, am I
lazy, am I delusional?
Am I rude, am I condescending?
Straight up tell me the truth.
I think a one month
setup, and I mean a month,
I mean it, where you get--
cause it's not--
nobody's gonna be comfortable telling,
like some people are too mean,
and they just wanna fucking be mean.
Some people are too nice
and wanna hold it back.
I struggle with candor, for example.
But if you spend a whole month getting
seven to 12 people that you spend
the most time with in this place,
and then have this intervention.
And you get them to feel safe to tell
you the truth,
I think you might get very clean data.
Which then you can--
what usually happens,
and I've had some people reach out to me.
What usually happens is,
nobody tells you something
that you didn't know,
they just tell you something that you wish
they didn't know.
And once you realize
everyone actually knows,
you start becoming more real.
- Mm-hmm, yeah, that makes sense.
So, I've done many years
of developing myself,
my own self-awareness.
I really believe that
it's closely developed
with a person's ability
to dream of success
in what they wanna do.
If someone does not have
a lot of self-awareness,
they might not be as ambitious or--
- It's funny you say that, Joshua,
I would argue with you that the people
that I feel struggle with
the most self-awareness
actually are delusional about success.
It's funny you took that route.
I have experienced a
little bit of the opposite.
I think that there are so many people
that sit in their coach
and play 2K all day
and smoke weed, and talk
about being a billionaire,
when they're not doing shit.
They're so delusional
about their ambitious goals,
that their actions aren't
even remotely close
to what the fuck is
coming out of their mouth.
And their self-awareness is laughable.
- Okay, I definitely see
where you're coming from on that.
I guess, what I was trying to say is,
people that are actually
taking those steps
towards success and they actually
on the proper route, they have to--
self-awareness is either
developed through that,
or they have to previously have had
that self-awareness.
- I see, I see, I agree
with both of those.
I think what's really cool about business
or ambition, and going through a process
is sports, music, a lot of things.
If you're fair, the market will tell you.
When you think you're gonna
be a basketball player,
and you're going through it,
and you're terrible.
To your point that
self-awareness is being taught
because you're seeing the actual results.
At the same token, conviction matters
because a lot of times,
it's just a micro loss,
but people take it as a macro loss,
and they give up.
Instead of persevering.
- Yeah, yeah, I totally agree with that.
- Yeah, awesome.
- Okay.
- Thanks for being on Josh.
- Yeah, of course.
Is it all right if I give
a shout out real quick
about what I do?
- Sure.
- So, I run a Discord server right now,
and I mentor people how to trade
on the stock market actually.
And that's kind of what Simply Trading is
on my screen.
And we have motivational stuff every day
where we go in, just haver a phone call
and we talk about people's success,
their failures, and what
they can do to kind of
better succeed every day, so--
- And is the Discord
that right there, Simply Trading?
- Yeah, that's my Discord,
it's also our YouTube and
our Instagram channel,
like go along with that.
- Okay, man, good luck.
- Awesome, thank you, you have a good one.
- You too.
Dustin with the early hook.
Dustin, you don't like the right hooks?
- No, (laughs) I was trying to mute
because when you're talking the--
- Got it, got it.
- The feedback's real bad,
but I hit the wrong button.
- No worries, all right.
Let's keep it going.
Big shout out to Jennifer Dalton.
Hey, Karena.
- Good morning, how are you doing?
- I'm well, how are you?
- Absolutely fantastic, thank you so much
for taking my call.
- Of course.
- And a huge thank you to Zane and Dustin
and everybody doing this,
they are doing so awesome,
and I super, super appreciate them.
- Thank you.
- So, here's my question.
I'm a mom, of course,
my daughter's wonderful
because she's my kid, but realistically,
she's a 13 year old girl.
She goes to public school, does karate,
loves Tik Tok, cause
she's a 13 year old girl.
- Yes.
- I'm a huge believer
in that whole tasting experience things.
Don't wanna just rely
on the school system,
they have their own problem,
their own struggles.
So, each year we try to find something
that's kind of glamorous,
but do like the dirty work of it.
So, a few years ago, she published a book.
The next year, her and her godmother
turned it into a movie.
So, she got like the back screen grid
of filming over and over.
Last year she wanted
to do public speaking,
so she emailed a bunch of principles
and spoke in like 60 some classrooms.
- Wow.
- So, doing the grit of it,
like getting experience.
- Yes, the process.
- Yeah, the process.
So, now we're in quarantine,
and I know there's some
sort of cool experience
for her to taste.
I just can't figure out what's
the best thing to do.
- What about hosting
virtual Zooms around topics
and being the conductor
and the orchestrator of it?
- That's a great idea!
- Well, that's why you keep--
- That is a super idea.
- Well, that's why you keep me around,
you think I'm here for my looks?
I mean, of course that's a great idea.
(laughs)
I'm just kidding, I'm kidding,
but I think it's a really good idea.
I think the challenge of finding
a subject matter, the
challenge of finding people
to come and join it.
And then, the challenge
of managing 25 people
on a Zoom call, it's an
incredible producer skill
that I think could really,
really be valuable for her,
and could be really fun.
And could really extend her network.
- That's a really, really good idea.
What area do you think would be the best
structured area to--
- I think she should pick either one
that is her learning about it.
So, she's kind of like the naive rookie
with a bunch of people
that do know about it,
or something she feels confident about.
I mean, if she did a Tik Tok kind of group
and was educating people
on what's really
happening in the trenches;
you'd probably find a
lot of small businesses
and entrepreneurs and others even in their
20s, 30s, 40s that would probably wanna
join that and listen.
- All right, thank you.
You just fired a 13 year old up on that.
- I love it, I love it.
- Awesome.
- Good luck.
- Thank you so much!
- You're welcome Karena, take care.
- Bye.
- Bye-bye.
All right, let's keep it going.
- Right, Facebook, Tik Tok, oh!
Gary (mumbles).
- What's good, bro?
- Yeah, what's good with you, man?
- Things are good, whoa.
Oh, you're back.
- Super, super grateful again.
Thank you so much for
taking time to do this.
You have no idea how
much this means to us.
So, a little bit of context
to kind of get into it.
So, I'm from Calgary, Canada,
was supposed to come see you in Edmonton,
which by the way, I saw,
perhaps September, yes?
- Yup, I did not want--
I mean, I was so fired up
about the Edmonton talk
cause I've never given
a big keynote there,
and so I am fighting super hard for it.
So, hopefully September, yes.
- Awesome.
So, a little bit of context here,
so I work in the news media and say,
well, a little bit about the media.
But I've been doing
that for about a decade,
and so my portfolio is,
is I manage our digital websites
right across Canada.
- Mm-hmm.
- So, we're talking, Montreal, Winnipeg,
Calgary, Edmonton, Vancouver.
So, daily there's a lot
of content that comes out
daily, daily, daily.
About a year ago, a year and a half ago,
I started a fitness business
because I was inspired.
I've always had the
entrepreneurial spirit,
when I was a kid, when I was 12 years old,
I started a paper route just because
I wanted to play Pokemon Blue.
That was my thing on the Game Boy, right?
- Yup.
- So, I've always had that spirit,
and I kind of pulled
the trigger early 2019,
been doing it for about a year.
And it's been really successful,
so what I ended up doing was,
a lot of my content
creation, and I'm everywhere.
LinkedIn, Tik Tok, Facebook,
Instagram, Twitter, everywhere,
I have my own blog, I started a podcast,
I've got it all.
And what I would do is,
I'd commute into work,
and the commute is about
45 minutes one way,
and I would do a lot of my work
on the train, right?
So, while everybody else
is searching the news,
I was working on my business,
right there on the phone.
- Yup.
- And it's amazing how much success I had
out of that.
Well, then COVID hit, and with COVID,
my entire days at work have shifted.
So, I'm working 10, 12,
13 hour days sometimes
dealing with the news,
that I'm just not finding the energy
to keep up, right?
I'm doing client services,
that's first and foremost.
I'm taking care of my
clients, I'm calling in,
I'm checking up on them.
I'm making sure that everything is really,
really good with the people
that I'm working with.
But outside of that,
how do I find the energy
to continue when I'm just so burnt out?
- Are you able to not go 10 and 13?
Are you able to carve out an hour
for lunch, or dinner, or breakfast,
or are you able to?
- I'd love to say yes,
the problem is though is,
I'm the manager of the department,
and I'm a team of two.
So, our news agency is very small
in consideration compared--
- Sure.
- We're no--
- BBC.
- Yeah, we're no big game players,
so it kind of all falls
on my shoulders, and--
- But it was falling on
your shoulders before,
but the rules of coming into the office
enabled you to have time,
is that what you would say?
- Yeah, absolutely.
Yeah, absolutely.
- So, talk to me about sleeping.
- So, it's funny that
you say that (laughs).
The day that everything
kind of went south,
when the NBA canceled their season,
we had our second child.
- Wow, congratulations.
- Yeah, thank you.
We have newborn life right now too,
so sleep is kind of iffy.
- Yeah, so here's what I would say.
I would say that you're
over judging yourself
in a tiny, tiny, tiny,
micro moment, Justin.
- Mm-hmm.
- I don't think you have
to find the motivation
in the time where COVID and a second child
hit at the same exact day.
I don't think you have to.
I don't think you--
- Mm-hmm.
- People feel like you have to be on point
always in perpetuity.
There's nothing wrong with you being off
and not motivated on your side hustle--
- Yeah.
- For four and a half months.
- Nothing will change.
- Yeah.
- I think you should
stop judging yourself.
- Yeah, but how do I--
The thing is, is I enjoy creating content,
that's the part I love.
- But you're tired right now.
- Yeah.
- I enjoy watching the Jets,
they're not playing.
- Mm-hmm, yeah.
- You're just not in that place right now.
- Yeah.
- It doesn't mean you
won't be in that place
on September 18th.
- Yeah, I just feel that there's
so much opportunity.
- There is.
- There's so much opportunity and I--
- But wasting four and a half months
isn't gonna mean shit.
All these things that I talk about,
there's polar opposite poles,
and they're both okay,
here's what I mean by that.
Wasting four and a half months
isn't gonna mean shit, just blew the mind
of a lot of people watching here.
Cause like, no, no, you
talk about going at it.
I'm like, yes, I do.
Yes, there's an unlimited amount
of opportunity every second.
- Mm-hmm.
- At the same token,
in the balance of actual life,
it's also super okay to not do dick shit
for four and a half months.
- Yeah.
- Especially, especially when it's
under this circumstance.
- Yeah.
- You have to manage
virtually during a pandemic
that happens once every hundred years,
at the same moment that
you had a second child.
- Yeah.
- Not doing dick shit for
four and a half months
when your parents are
paying for your lifestyle
and you're fucking sitting
and fucking doing shit.
That's not exciting.
- Yeah.
- You, you specifically right now,
take a breathe and just fucking enjoy
having a second child,
and take care of your business,
and just don't over worry.
I understand it brings you happiness,
by the way, this is not a joke.
Garage sailing in the spring and summer
really helps me.
It's like an escape for all my stress.
I don't have that, and that's okay.
- Yeah, and I'm not completely--
like I'm not doing dick shit.
I mean, I'm still--
- Then even better,
then you're just over judging yourself.
- Yeah.
- You're being impatient.
- Mm-hmm.
- And judgemental against your own self.
Yeah, I mean, I always--
- For no reason.
- I mean, I always grew up that way,
and I feel like I'm an overachiever, and--
- Yeah, but you need to
build a real relationship
between ambition and
love for your own self.
- Mm-hmm.
So, should I carve out
more time to practice that
or more time to create content?
It doesn't matter.
You should focus on not
beating yourself up.
- Mm-hmm, yeah.
I mean, my wife, she's this real super
star right now, but
she's doing what she can,
but I'm in crisis mode at work.
And sometimes the baby's crying,
and I gotta get up and I gotta--
with the news cycle, it's just non-stop,
it's non-stop.
- Listen, you know what else was non-stop,
World War Two, and Hurricane Katrina,
and the Black Plague.
- Yeah.
- Yeah, life.
- Yeah, so just pause,
stop judging myself,
and just wait for it to pass.
- 100%, cause I dunno if you heard,
it's going to.
COVID won't be here forever--
- Yeah.
- And your second baby
won't be three weeks old forever.
- Yeah.
- This is the fun time,
where you have to eat shit.
You have to glamorize the crap.
You know what I do when it's crap,
I think about nine years from now
talking about the crap.
- Mm-hmm.
- And being grateful for the non-crap.
It's as if people only want it
to be good all the time.
- Yeah.
- As if they--
people are so entitled,
like what we were the--
all us humans watching right now,
we were supposed to be
part of the generation
that just lived 100 years
with all prosperity and good.
That's not how the fucking world works.
- Yeah.
- So, people were living nice and calm,
and the Genghis Khan came to their town
and killed them.
I don't understand, people are confused.
You know how many
people's lives were saved
cause of COVID?
My dear friend, Nipsy Hustle died
a year ago during COVID.
If COVID happened a year ago,
he wouldn't have been out,
he would have been in his home.
He'd be alive, he
probably would have lived
for another 60 years.
Kobe Bryant wouldn't have been
on that fucking plane if COVID started
just a month earlier.
- Mm-hmm, perspective.
- Perspective, man.
Yes, there's a lot of bad,
there's also a lot of good,
and for you just listening
and getting your vibe,
fuck this, man, enjoy the shit eating.
Enjoy the big--
sometimes you gotta grab
the baby, hold the baby,
and be on your computer
at 1:13 in the morning,
and look at the fucking reflection
of the computer and
just smile at yourself.
That you were fucking
built for this shit too.
- That's real man.
- I dunno why people just smile
when they're on the beach
with a fucking pina colada.
Sometimes you gotta
fucking smile at your face
when the baby just took a shit
and it's 1:12 in the morning,
and the person you're managing
isn't fucking showing up.
You just gotta look
at the fucking computer
screen, see your face,
and just smile at yourself, like,
let's fucking go!
- Yeah.
Yeah.
Let's go, dude.
- Got it?
- And man, I'm like, I'm live streaming
right now on my own pages because--
- Good.
- I have to--
I don't have to, but you know
what I mean, I just--
- Yeah.
- Let's get some content, let's grow,
let's make sure that
we're doing what we can.
Because I don't wanna quit,
this is my passion,
this is my side hustle--
- Of course you're not gonna quit,
you're not quitting,
you're adjusting to the
reality of the situation
for a micro moment in the scheme
of your hundred years of life.
- Yeah.
- People struggle with perspective,
it's just the one thing I was gifted with,
and I fucking adore it,
and it's very easy for
me to articulate at.
And this (mumbles) minutes is really easy,
sometimes you just gotta smile at shit.
You know there's that scene in the movies,
where the tough guy gets
punched in the face?
Gets punched and the blood comes out,
and then the next moment,
comes back and he just smiles at you.
That's me when shits bad, I like it,
and I want more people to like it,
because it's part of the equation.
- Mm-hmm.
- It's part of the game,
and I think people need to start
enjoying the dirt more.
- Yeah, bro, could I grab a picture?
- Yup.
- Awesome.
Thank you so much, Gary.
- Good luck brother, take care.
- See ya.
- Stay well.
- Oo, that was a little bit of a moment.
Dust, let's make sure the team clips that,
that needs to get on the gram.
- Got it.
- Mm-hmm.
Jess, how are you?
- Hi!
Hello, I'm good, how are you?
- I'm well.
- So, my question is, pretty much,
I've been struggling with trying
to stay true to myself.
I make videos on YouTube,
and I've been doing this
for about three years or so.
I started off doing natural hair,
honestly, I was just
always a creative person,
but I just decided to
try to do creative stuff
to my hair, just because
I was in that journey
at that time in my life.
- I love it.
- And as I got older, I kind of realized
that I really just want
to inspire other girls
to love themselves naturally.
Promote natural beauty,
because I know when I first started,
I could not get on the
computer, or I mean,
I couldn't go on video without make-up,
I couldn't walk out the house.
I had to just--
everything was just
perfect and I just cared
about how I looked,
but as I got older, I was like,
that stuff doesn't really matter.
But now, it's like,
now that I'm transitioning
into natural beauty,
and loved your stuff,
but the audience that I already built,
they want the natural hair glam girl.
- You've gotta adjust,
you gotta leave them behind.
I lived this Jess, I--
my first year of doing business content
and not wine content,
my audience was on Tilt,
and they disa--
and a lot of them, 70%, 90% of them left.
- Mm-hmm, yeah.
- Just like you have the self-esteem,
and I'm so proud of you to not give a fuck
about quote on quote, looking perfect.
- Mm-hmm.
- You now have to not
give a fuck about losing
viewers and subscribers,
that's your next step.
- Yeah, yeah, that's true,
and then also, I tried to promote--
this is like, I mean, the
natural hair community
is pretty much, you know,
girls who rock their natural hair.
And I tried to--
I used to not follow anyone else,
because I have--
I'm very competitive,
(laughs)
and I can get into the state
where I'm trying to compare myself,
but I feel like I'm closed off
into the community.
So, I've tried to go out
and follow other girls
and everything like that,
but then I find myself, like okay,
well, they get a lot of views
because they're doing,
and then they're keeping on trend,
and they're showing their make-up.
Then I'm overthinking, why is--
- Yeah, you've gotta get jealousy and envy
out of your body, you've gotta practice.
Their success and happiness has nothing
to do with you.
The world is abundant, Jess.
They're not stealing your views.
- Yeah, yeah.
- Darling, listen to me,
the world is abundant,
nobody's stealing your views.
I know so many people that are competitive
with other influencers,
and content makers,
it's destroying them.
As if somebody else's success
has anything to do with you.
It's a very ugly trait, envy and jealousy
is a fucking poison.
- Mm-hmm.
- It's poison, you
should be happy for them.
- Yeah.
- You gotta learn this,
you gotta learn this,
I'm telling you right now.
You don't train this one,
you don't tweak this one,
you're gonna be in a bad place forever.
Tearing down somebody else's building
to make your building
feel big is loser shit.
- Mm-hmm, and I do care about--
I mean, I want others to be successful.
- Of course.
- But it's just hard,
hard trying to rebrand myself when I see--
I mean, yeah, I mean--
(laughs)
- You know where this is going.
Yeah, you know you're
not gonna win this game
cause you already know you can--
I can feel your smartness on this
cause you've already--
Look, you have the luxury
of being naturally beautiful,
so it's been easy to go natural.
- (laughs) Thank you.
- Listen to me, you have
to go back to zero followers in your mind.
That's what I did.
- Yeah, mm-hmm.
- You have to go back to zero,
and I'm telling you right now,
you will pick up a bigger audience
of being your true self
than trying to hold on
to just hack the
algorithm, or the fan base
for another view.
- Mm-hmm.
- You're not that girl anymore.
- Mm-hmm, yeah, and that's so true--
- By the way, this is a big deal Jess,
because this is about
to happen to everybody
cause kids are about to get more famous,
more often, earlier because of Tik Tok
and YouTube, and Instagram.
But then they're gonna through life,
and they're not gonna be the same person.
- Mm-hmm, mm-hmm, and that's true.
I even told myself, I'm like,
I wish I could just start from zero
because I feel like all of my subscribers
are not even--
- You can!
You can.
- But what is the point?
- You can.
- Yeah, in the head, in
my head, yes, yes, yes,
you're right, you're right (laughs).
And I have one more question,
so the reason why I'm on here is because
actually my boyfriend helped me find you.
It was cause of him,
and I feel like, anyways, I just wanted--
could I ask a question for him?
- Of course.
- Is that possible?
- That's possible.
- Well, he wants to--
I've been trying to tell him about getting
on social media as well.
He's so anti it, he does not--
he's a scorpio, I dunno if that--
but he doesn't like being--
- He's a what?
- A scorpio, I dunno if that--
- You know who else is a scorpio?
- You, I know!
(laughs)
I know.
- There goes that fucking theory.
- I know (laughs),
but anyways, he's really--
he loves cars, just
being in his car driving,
he loves the car culture,
and I've said, start
your own YouTube channel,
but he doesn't know.
How do you start a YouTube channel to--
- I would tell--
how old is he?
- He's 24.
- You have to get him on Tik Tok.
- Tik Tok?
- Let me tell you why,
it will work there, he'll
get feedback quickly.
Oh, is he in the building?
- Yeah, he's right here.
- Get over here, what's his name?
- Okay, Blake (laughs).
- What's up, bro?
- What's going on, Gary?
- What's good, bro?
- What's going on?
- Thanks for putting me on.
(laughs)
- Of course, thank you.
Thank you for all your time.
- Of course, bro, Tik Tok, bro.
Tik Tok bro, listen, she's right,
you could always stop it.
- Mm-hmm.
- This is just all about just--
it's all just about self-confidence,
self-awareness, it's really just not
giving a fuck what people think.
- Okay.
- Not yourself, not your homies,
once you go there--
- Mm-hmm.
- I promise, what's going on
on Tik Tok right now,
especially youth culture
around kind of like, Grand Theft Auto,
like speed cars, like all that shit.
There's some real fuck--
and bro, and it's real opportunity.
- Okay.
- You make one video
that fucking pops off,
now you got fucking Maserati DM'ing you
saying yo, do you wanna drive?
Like shit that you dream of
can happen by you making--
- Okay.
- You see where I'm going?
- Yeah, I get it.
- It's not about you have to become
the biggest or maker a million bucks.
It's about you might be able
to fucking test drive a car
that's not in the market
because all the brands
are about to get really
focused on Tik Tok.
And if you're that guy,
you're gonna have a life experience
that you'd be dreaming of.
It just costs making a Tik Tok video.
- Okay.
- And I can vouch for that,
because of you I went on Tik Tok,
and yeah, I see the results already.
- And Jess, that's a platform
where you don't have to work.
That is a platform where you're starting
at zero, so go ham
on what you wanna be talking about.
- Yes, thank you.
- All right, guys, take care.
Have a great day, see ya, see ya.
- Bye.
- Great, you too.
- Nice meeting you.
I dunno what happened over the weekend,
but I'm fucking sharp as a fucking knife
this morning, stuffs coming out hot.
I dunno if you guys are feeling it.
Dustin, I dunno if you're--
Get in here, Dust.
I dunno if you're feeling it, Dust,
but I'm fucking--
I'm fucking wise as shit this morning.
- When you first came
into the stream today,
I was a little like--
- Worried?
- Cause you looked like
you were kind of like--
- Yeah, I was.
- Not in a good mood.
- I wasn't, I had a real--
because you know, most don't, I work--
- Yeah, yeah.
- And have real responsibilities,
and I had an interesting,
frustrating moment
before I came on.
- Yeah, I could tell, and then--
- Yeah.
- But then I just--
that's why when you come on here,
you just feel so much better (laughs).
- Yeah, I do, once the lights go on,
(laughs)
come on, you know?
All right, let's keep it going,
let's get one more in.
- Yup.
- I did Derek, I got real life stuff.
Sawyer, what's good?
- What's up, Gary?
I'm super, super grateful
for this opportunity, dude.
- Appreciate it.
- I'm a tori old farmer slash entrepreneur
from South East Iowa, small town.
- Love it.
- I didn't go to college,
and you were one of
the biggest influencers
on that decision.
And honestly, it's been the best decision
I could have made for myself.
- Good for you.
- I got super self-aware.
I knew I wanted to be a farmer,
and I also wanted to
pursue entrepreneurship,
and I knew--
and having a farm and running a farm
with your family
is kind of a business in itself.
(blows out air loudly)
- Big time.
- So, I always kind of use that.
I wanna have a business,
but I also wanna build
something on my own,
and on the side, and get money.
Make money from something else
other than the farm to help grow the farm.
- I understand.
- So, my biggest aspiration
is to build a brand
around my farm, which I'm doing right now,
and launch a company off the backend
of my audience.
- I love it.
- And that's my biggest dream,
that's my biggest aspiration.
My biggest struggle is
not seeing the likes,
I don't care about the likes.
I'm super, I don't care about that.
- That's all right, you're patient, yeah.
- The biggest thing I have,
the biggest struggle I
have is entrepreneurship
as you know is a lonely road.
- Yeah.
- And so is being in South East Iowa,
as you know.
- (laughs) Yeah.
- Or you don't know,
you grew up in New York,
but there's not a lot of people--
- No, but bro, it's funny, bro it's funny,
don't get it twisted.
Where my parents live, we're in farm co--
(laughs)
Bro, I had a cow in my high school years.
- (laughs) Oh, crap (laughs).
- My high school was 25 minutes away
from where I lived.
I grew up mainly in Edison
where it was definitely multi-cultural,
super city vibe, that kind of place.
- Mm-hmm.
- Like a New York suburb,
but then my high school years were here
in fucking hunting season, fucking pigs--
- That's dope.
- I fucking, I told my parents,
I never tell my pig shit story.
My dad had pigs.
- (laughs) I have pigs.
- Bro, I fucking, I got
a little farm in me, bro,
so I gotta little farm in me.
- (laughs) There we go, awesome.
- Okay?
- Yeah, so--
- So, I get it, so it's lonely, right?
- Yeah, yes.
- Lacking people.
- And farming is lonely as well,
it's just me and my dad running this,
and I just feel so isolated.
- So, let's do this,
let's create an
entrepreneurial group for you
right now, do you have
an Instagram account?
- Yeah, I'm mostly active on--
at my farm account,
it's at This'll Do Farm
on all platforms, Tik Tok, YouTube--
- What is that one more time?
- At This'll Do Farm.
- This will do farm?
- This'll do, like this'll
do, you know like--
- This'll do.
- Yeah, this'll do.
- Can you spell it so, is that--
- T-H-I-S, here, let me just show you.
(laughs)
- Is it like, this will do, as in Babe?
- Like this'll, like--
- No, I say, take the W out.
- T-H-I-S-L-L.
- Just take the--
right, take out the W,
you're looking at it.
- Yeah, take the W out and the I,
and it's just This'll Do Farm.
- Got it, no W, no I.
- No W, no I.
- Let's hope--
watch this.
- Like a comma.
- So, watch this, yup, I got you,
but there's no comma
in the handles, right?
So, it's--
- No, there's no comma
in the handle, yeah.
- So, is that it?
Look at it.
- Yeah, that's it.
- Good.
- On all platforms.
- Good, how many--
let's see how many
fucking followers you have
on your Instagram right now.
So, what I'm gonna do is,
I'm gonna send everybody to your Instagram
that's an entrepreneur.
- Oh, crazy (laughs).
- Or that likes--
(laughs)
- Crazy, yeah.
- So, right now you have--
bro, you're doing well!
- I do, I've been following
you for years, man.
- I can see it, I see the content, it lo--
you've got, bro you're doing a nice job.
- Thank you very much, I appreciate it.
- 7610, 7624, 7628.
- I know that my audience is on YouTube,
that's mostly where the
farm community lives at,
but I'm just doing--
I post a vlog every week on YouTube,
and then chop up my micro content
just like you say.
Post it on Instagram, Tik Tok--
- Sawyer, here's what's gonna happen,
you're starting to get
a bunch of followers.
I'm gonna ask everybody
who's following Sawyer
and This'll Do Farm to leave a comment
on his latest post, I'll do the same.
It's a nice little
photo, I like the photos.
Are you taking those photos?
- Yeah, I'm doing all the content myself.
- Bro, you're doing a good job.
- Thank you very much.
- I saw my man, Rips Cards is in there,
he's a young hustler
that does card flipping.
- Awesome, awesome.
- Here's what I want,
people are leaving comments
right now, it's starting to already.
A lot of people have followed already,
you're up to 7,800.
- (laughs) Crazy (laughs).
- I want everybody to
leave a comment, and say--
- Thank you so much.
- Basically, leave a comment and say,
I'll join the community,
I'll join the community.
I think you need to
start a Facebook group.
- Okay.
- Or some other close community,
I think Facebook groups
is a great infrastructure for this.
Or DM everybody who leaves a comment
to a URL, and you should start a Zoom,
or a Google Hangout thing, bro,
there's so many people.
First of all, your contents so good,
that I think you can help a lot of people
that are on here right now.
- Appreciate that.
- So, you could be
shooting the shit there,
this and that.
I think there's something
really good, bro.
- Thank you very much, I appreciate that.
- Bro, you're--
this is really well done.
- Thank you, thank you.
That means a lot coming from you.
- It's so well done,
I'm adding one picture of you being crazy
with the pigs in my stories.
- (laughs) Oh, my God, thank you so much.
- You're welcome, bro.
- Hey, tell Caleb, his homie from Iowa,
gotta go on a Zoom call with ya.
- My Caleb?
- Yeah, Caleb.
- That's your guy?
- Yeah, that's my guy.
- 8,000 now.
- (laughs) Yeah, crazy.
- We're growing here, baby.
- Crazy, thank you so much.
Yeah, I just--
that's my biggest thing like--
- So, listen--
- Go ahead.
- You're getting a ton of people,
you're getting a ton of people
that are leaving comments.
Here's lottery life,
Lottery of Life who said,
"Bro, I used to be a farm hand
on a 300 acre farm."
Caleb just said this is hilarious,
so he's fired up.
(laughs)
- Awesome.
- Bro, you're getting a ton of like--
you've got 300 comments
on this latest post.
- Crazy (laughs), oh my God.
Thank you so much.
- So, what's interesting though
is these people wanna be your friend.
- Right.
- So, these people will become
your virtual friends.
- Mm-hmm.
- If you basically ask
everybody right now,
if you reply to everybody and say,
could you reply with your email.
As a matter of fact, everybody start
replying with your email.
If they reply with their email,
you put it into an email list,
and then you email them
out a Google Hangout
link every night,
and just let's all shoot the shit
for 35, 40 minutes.
- Mm-hmm.
- A bunch of people are
about to become friends.
- Exactly, yeah, that's awesome.
I never even thought
about doing that really.
- Yeah, bro, you could be living
in a virtual city.
- (laughs) There you go, yeah, for sure,
and everybody's got a great mindset, so,
yeah, that's awesome.
- Definitely in this community.
- Yeah.
- It's the right kind.
- Yeah, yeah, true.
- So, I'm gonna hang up,
and you need to go start replying to all--
let's see how many.
You had 294, now you have--
comments, now you have--
on your latest post,
you're up to 400 comments.
- (laughs) Oh my God.
- And these are people that are like,
just trying to like,
people are just leaving
their email already, matt@rittertime.
- Mm-hmm.
- People are just like--
just wanna be fucking.
- That's nuts.
- You know?
Can I ask you one last thing?
- Yes.
- Real quick, when do
you think is a good time
to launch a company off the backend
of your audience?
I know you preach trust,
but trust with your audience.
- Well, what do you wanna sell?
What do you wanna sell?
- Well, I was thinking maybe a direct
to consumer pork Iowa pork box,
because we produce a lot of pigs,
or I wanna go different.
I think a bunch of people just
do a lot of clothing companies off
the backend of audiences.
I was thinking--
- I want pork.
- This'll, I was thinking of doing
like a This'll Do tool company.
Doing a tool company
or something totally different.
- I think the pork thing is super smart.
- Yeah.
- And I think, what I've
been seeing in the box
or month space, is the ability to--
thank you.
Is the ability to do it quarterly.
- Okay.
- You know?
- If you created it
called, pork of the season,
and you do it in January,
April, August, November.
- Yeah.
- I think you'll--
you got one customer right now.
- (laughs) Crazy, do
you think that I should
continue to put out cont--
obviously put out content,
or do you think I should continue
to build that trust?
Or do you think wait a couple years,
build the trust?
- Do you know what's funny?
Food is a good one,
because obviously a lot
people don't eat pork,
cause their diets.
- Right.
- But people that do,
it's kind of kind of like
Wine Text, right?
- Mm-hmm.
- The reason I get so pissed,
and in a year when you turn 21,
(laughs)
you better fucking sign up, bro.
- I will, don't you worry.
- Because, for me, it's like, if anybody--
if you're bringing people value,
if they're going to the
store and buying pork,
why wouldn't they buy it from you?
- Right.
- It's kind of how I feel
about Wine Text, right?
- Mm-hmm.
- I get so pissed because I'm like,
I'm not even gonna ask for myself,
but I ask for my dad.
I'm like, first of all when it's great,
and I'm sure, fresh
from farm pork direct--
- Iowa pork, yeah.
- Yeah, bro, I want
that fucking Iowa pork.
- (laughs) That'll be my selling point,
is Iowa pork is supposed to the best
in the world, and cause
we're the number one
leading pork producing state, so--
- Bro, I'm about that Iowa pork.
- (laughs) All right, hell yeah.
- I would sign up for a subscription
to get some fucking pork once a quarter.
- (laughs) Awesome.
- Is pork different in
different times a year?
Is there like a way to make it unique,
that in January they're a little fatter?
In August, it's a little leaner.
- Nah, not really.
- Not really.
- Not really, but--
- I'm trying to think
about what you can add,
if you could add a vegetable to it,
or a recipe, or--
there's a lot you can do.
- Mm-hmm, right, yeah.
I was thinking about
maybe people being able
to customize their box,
and put whatever they
kind of cuts they want
in their box.
- Yes.
- Do you know what I mean?
- Yes, I do.
- If you want pork loin,
or you want more of this.
- I think, I would push you
to have less customization and more scale.
So, one month is pork, one quarter.
I think four times a year pork loin,
I don't fucking know shit.
(laughs)
I just wanna eat snout,
can you save some snout
for me, bro?
- (laughs) You want the snout.
- I eat snout.
Yeah, dude's the snout's delicious.
- I can make that happen.
- Yeah, I'm about the snout.
So, anyway, I gotta run,
I'm already late for my thing,
but I'm having fun.
- All right, thank you.
- Talk to you soon.
- Thank you.
You got it, brother.
Talk to ya, see ya.
- See ya.
All, right, we're outta here.
Make it very simple,
if you don't do it now,
I'm just kind of finished, winetext.com,
sign up, All-In Challenge.
Please go buy a $10 raffle ticket
to my experience, which is remarkable.
I'm gonna send you off with it right now,
and thank you everybody who was watching,
and most of all, please
go to Twitter right now,
and hit me up at Gary V-E-E,
just like every channel.
And just gimme a sense of--
tell me that you just
signed up for Wine Text,
tell me what you thought the best part
of today's show was.
And by the way, I see a lot
of you in the comments,
how do you get on this show?
Very easily, 212-931-5731,
212-931-5731, text me your question,
use #teawithgaryvee, we
will see you tomorrow.
I am giving away the
ultimate GaryVee experience.
How should that go?
Okay, over the last week or so,
I've been jamming with
my friend, Michael Rubin,
and helping out on this All-In Challenge.
That I am accepting right now,
but allinchallenge.com, please go there,
we are challenging some
of the greatest artists,
entertainers, athletes in the world
to provide a ridiculous
all time experience
or one of their most iconic items
in their collection.
To help raise money to
help feed the hungry
during this ridiculous time,
and so now, I have to put up my auction.
So, my auction, the
ultimate GaryVee experience
here we go, I'm gonna go
off the top of the head,
and you can go on allinchallenge.com
to go bid on this.
I am giving away--
Okay, you get to, in the course of a year,
you will go garage sailing with me,
and film Trash Talk.
Also, you can get a workout
with me and Mike Vacanti.
So, I know a lot of you pay attention
to that part of my world.
Also, we're gonna go to Wine Library,
and do a $25,000 shopping spree.
That's right, I'm gonna
pay my dad (laughs),
well, I'm gonna donate.
We're gonna pay my dad 25,000,
so $25,000 shopping spree at Wine Library.
I will walk through the
whole store with you,
tell you the war stories,
and you'll buy a bunch
of wine, beer, liquor,
whatever you want, food.
We are going to go to
a Jets game together.
You're gonna tailgate with me,
I never do this.
When I give away Jets tickets,
I never let the person sit with me,
so you'll sit with me
during the Jets game.
I won't talk to you during the game,
I'm completely focused,
but you'll get that.
So, the ultimate Jets
experience, tailgate,
full game with me as well.
Also, I'm going to give you one week
play at VaynerMedia.
So, this is for you and
a plus one, by the way,
so the two tickets, the--
we'll do some plus one's,
we'll do some just me and you,
depending on what it is.
One full week at VaynerMedia
getting consulting
and business advice
from team GaryVee and me
for the entire week.
Hanging out in the pit
where the show's done.
You're gonna be a guest of my podcast,
we're gonna do a wine dinner for you,
and seven of your friends
at Hunt & Fish Club
in New York City.
And I'm gonna fly you, all paid, plus one,
to three of my keynotes,
and we'll work on those details.
The ultimate GaryVee experience.
I hope you bid on it, I
hope you get involved,
I hope we raise a lot of money
to help people that need it.
Also, what's so fun about
the All-In Challenge,
is you get to challenge
people to be in it.
I am gonna challenge all
the Vayner sports athletes,
I expect you in there,
so that is number one.
Number two, I'm gonna go
with, oo, you know what?
Timbaland, the super producer,
who's completely lighting up Instagram.
I'm calling you out.
And finally, I got one, The Undertaker.
One of the great wrestlers of all time,
please join the challenge.
Everybody go to allinchallenge.com,
please support this,
the experiences are gonna be nuts.
We've been working,
bleeding out of the eyeballs
for the last week,
putting this all together.
You're gonna be blown away
what you're about to see on social media.
#allinchallenge, please check it out,
and please go to your
favorite celebrities,
athletes and entertainers,
and leave #allinchallenge
to get them involved.
The All-In Challenge, please, take it.